politique encore avec la crise traversée
en ce moment par le ps des yvelines
le bureau national du parti a remercié
la secrétaire départementale sandrine
grand gambe
en poste depuis 2012 sanctionné pour
avoir rejoint le groupe europe ecologie
les verts au conseil régional d'île de
france avec son mentor benoît hamon
c'est le numéro deux dé socialiste des
yvelines
ali rabais qui a pris la tête de la
fédération départementale par intérim
il est également est également très
proche de benoît hamon son objectif
principal et préparer le congrès
national du ps qui se déroulera en
février 2018 ali rabais souhaite que
l'union des siens soient maintenus à
tout prix propos recueillis par nicolas
kirillovitch l'enjeu qui va se poser
pour moi mais pour tous les militants du
parti socialiste c'est est ce que le
prochain congrès sera un moment de débat
et de rassemblement du parti socialiste
qui nous permettra d'échanger réellement
sur le fond et de contribuer au
relèvement de la gauche qui ne passera
pas que par le parti socialiste
si la réponse est oui et j'espère que
que c'est oui en tout cas je contribue
tous les jours et j'ai contribuerait
pour ça le soit
évidemment je resterai au parti
socialiste si je constate que l'objectif
de ceux qui préparent le prochain
congrès ce sera uniquement d'éliminer
tel ou tel socialiste non je lui
trouverais pas ma place à titre
personnel